welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss this is new Rockstar's reaction to
the new trailer for the Marvels I'm here
with mt Tommy bechtold and Brandon Berry
hey everybody hello everybody
I feel marvelous
do you think it's gonna be fun so
Jessica Clements and I will be breaking
down all the Easter eggs in this trailer
for a video coming to the new Rockstar
Channel tomorrow but right here right
now we Beastie Boys are going
Intergalactic to react to our girls
kamalakon Monica Rambo and Carol Danvers
this trailer I'm so excited y'all ready
yeah let's do it here we
what the hell are you doing
in perimeter
I'm gonna get you some readings Fury I'm
so happy she's back oh more hex oh my
God what is this
oh is it yeah
[Laughter]
that's hilarious oh she knows him
Siri was a ghost
oh
so where was Carol and why do they why
can't they breathe on the moon
this music is amazing oh
the music choice is pretty and come here
I love I mean it's just like a d23
oh yeah I love the family
[Applause]
yes
she's got the
oh
um they hate each other
uh oh good this is a creature
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love you Goose where have you been
so good oh where is this
oh dance sequence
let's go let's go we're fighting each
other
no no no we're not we're not a team
I freaking love this I I love this so
much
oh my God okay so the four of us are
just going to quickly give some thoughts
some general reactions and then I uh
we're gonna end with like everyone's
gonna get 16 seconds on the clock to
give their hot take on this movie based
off of this trailer
um but just to kind of like point out
what we just saw there so Captain Marvel
being directed by Nina cuts that coming
November 10th 2023 it got pushed back
from July so we got Carol Danvers Brie
Larson Monica Rambo played by Tiana
Paris and Kamala County played by Iman
villani all three of these women coming
together it seemed to be entangled their
powers are entangled in some weird way
to where anytime they use their powers
they accidentally swap places with one
of the other ones and that's what
happened in the the ending the
post-credits scene of Ms Marvel uh and
we have a lot of questions like where
was Carol Danvers in that moment why did
why was she fighting with other decree
what exactly is this Mission Monica
Rambo is on what is this Rift in reality
I have a lot of thoughts and theories on
that it's that way Ashton explained some
unknown villain that looks like she's
connected to Ronan the Accuser because
she's got his staff that was the villain
of Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 and in
the 2019 Captain Marvel film she we
thought she might be a Creed General
like General uh ail Don or Dar Ben but
it looks like she's part of the uh Ronin
family tree remember that was like a
lineage that was passed down to him he
like all of his ancestors have hated the
zandarian race uh and that was part of
his callback movie and it looks like she
has a zombie action's character has
another bangle in this that she is using
so that might be where the other bangle
is that might be why she's uh waiting uh
Kamala Khan here is that like the the
Bengal a lot of us have speculated is
Cree Tech okay that's my take on this
when I'm out and about and listening to
something I want to hear that thing not
the people around me at the coffee shop
or on the plane I used to feel like to
make that happen I had to spend a
bazillion dollars on sci-fi technology
to block out sound but then I found
raycon raycon annoying sounds gone
raycon is on a mission to prove that you
shouldn't have to pay an arm and La for
Quality sound an essential smart Tech
listening features raycon's everyday
earbuds offer not only noise isolation
so you can shut out the world around you
but also awareness mode for those times
when you're waiting for your name to be
called so you can grab that cold brew
from that Barista plus raycon's everyday
earbuds shipped with custom gel tips for
the most comfortable in-ear fit and
raycon knows that in this economy every
purchase needs to be perfect which is
why they offer buy now pay later options
they have an easy and free return
guarantee but if over 50 000 5 Star
reviews are anything to go by you're not
going to need it and now new rockstars
viewers can click the link in the
description box or go to buy raycon.com
new rockstars to get 15 off your raycon
purchase
um but let's let's go around the horn
here uh empty I want to hear from you
first what what did you think of this I
love this so much like it seems like a
like a buddy cop type of film
um like a like a like a buddy Adventure
where these three people are just like
meeting each other and like I like weird
in my media and like this is just like
all right we're jumping in between space
I have like how to win when we use our
powers like that is so weird to me and
like so so much fun and like I like this
idea of quantum entanglements like I had
a feeling that's what was going on and
I'm so happy that they're going with
this yeah for sure uh and uh Brandon
what did you think I love the humor I'm
already seeing in this it looks like a
lot of fun uh a lot of similar footage
we saw at d23 which I think was great
that really popped the crowd uh at that
event so I'm glad to see a lot of that
same stuff here and I loved seeing
ronan's Hammer again I love Robin the
accuser I don't agree with him but I
like I like that character a lot that's
not what you said yesterday Brandon he
was at the you know we saw him in
Captain Marvel he was gonna come back to
earth to be like we'll deal with this
lady later uh and I love whoever's kind
of taking up his cause is like yeah we
got to get rid of all of these marbles
all over the place um I'm so happy to
see that come back again and of course
Goose you gotta love seeing Goose again
yes yes lots of
I'm glad you brought that up Eric
because I was gonna say this movie this
trailer was a roller coaster for guys
seeing the return of the Khan family uh
my favorite uh Disney plus TV family uh
the Lowe's a pack of flergs running down
the stairs where we can only assume
getting ready to just tentacle eat a
bunch of people they can't all be bad
Eric they can't all be going and not
every person eaten by a flirt could be
evil there's got to be some collateral
damage Justice for the wrongly eaten is
what I say I am I know you didn't ask me
my thoughts but I'll go ahead and give
them uh because I want to say this movie
comes out on November 10th it's my
birthday I'm gonna have a birthday party
themed around the Marvels I've said this
before I'm hoping to run out of theater
and watch it with as many of my closest
friends as possible and you're all
invited uh yes and the three of you the
Unseen fans stay away from me as always
do not approach me I am unapproachable I
am not available no I'm kidding
hopefully we can I want to watch it with
as many people as possible and I want to
eat a big slice of cake right at the end
as the Marvels Prevail as I hope I'm in
I'm all in I give it 10 marbles out of
10. nice so uh one thing I wanted to ask
specifically Brandon and Tommy about we
were at d23 we saw the d23 version of
this trailer it looks almost exactly the
same even down to the use of uh the
Beastie Boys Intergalactic which it's a
perfect song choice for this not just
because it's a great it's like a great
Jam but it's like yes we're going
Intergalactic but the fact that there's
three members of the Beastie Boys it
doesn't feel like the three members of
the Marvels right now they're all kind
of yelling over each other but like
doing it in a way that feels like
they're in sync with each other picking
it for the last one left off helping
each other finish each other's rhyme
like don't tell me
and they're all like saying
girls here and I'm like
I'm like different I feel like different
thing is like the depiction of Zoe
Ashton's character didn't she seem more
alien like in the d23 trailer whereas
here she just kind of looks like more
fashionable I wish we had access to that
footage because you know it's been a
while so that was nice to see it but
you're right A lot of it seemed very
familiar but I think you're right I
think she did seem more I hate to use
the word ornate
but uh she seemed more adorned with uh
with with extras where she seems much
more humanoid uh in this trailer so
right and I don't remember her carrying
ronan's Hammer I feel like that was new
yeah because that's a pretty big detail
yeah yeah and I feel like that whole
land it's giving me grease it's giving
me Mykonos right this like kind of uh
the white buildings and the seaside
aesthetic of it like that all felt very
new to me I don't remember everything
felt very spaceship I felt in what we
saw d23 I I hate to bring everything
back to the bad batch but you know I
will this season on the bad batch they
gave us space grease in the form of the
planet Pabu and I feel like Marvel said
hold my beer we're gonna give you a
bigger Intergalactic
so so good good good good on them yeah
that looked beautiful I'd like to
vacation there I'm a little afraid of
the uh cats that have tentacles that fly
out of their mouth and eat you but you
know what as I've been told uh if
there's tentacles lay down if there's
claws stand talls right that's that's
the role for when that's what you've
been told yes yes
I love it all right let's close with
some uh moonshot theories yeah like just
some real reach theories of who what do
we think is going to be the craziest way
this movie sets up the cosmic MCU uh
I'll go first I think this will be a
movie that introduces Silver Surfer
Galactus
The Herald of Galactus man I drink a
whole cup of coffee and nothing perked
me off like that statement Eric that was
that was more than 10 voltasas I would
love that I personally would love to see
the Shia Empire appear at some point in
the world just introduce that because
like Miss Marvel introduced the concept
of mutants being connected to Miss
Marvel and the Shia is very much
connected to uh the mutant narrative so
I would love it that would be dope I
think this movie is gonna finally
explain the connection of the Bengals
the ten rings and I think they're gonna
throw ronan's hammer in there somehow I
think all of this technology is going to
be connected in some Grand cree-esque
explanation I think we'll finally get an
answer to that I'm hoping they gotta
give us some answers here please I love
that okay mine is in the form of a cute
little Rhyme or a cute a cute little
song of course new series but keep the
old Eric's was silver and mine is gold
edible warlock will appear in this movie
oh beautiful I would love that hey I
gotta say for however early it is I'm
pretty proud of myself for that uh you
should be proud
oh my god
um okay so uh thank you all for watching
this uh reaction to it uh thank you Mt
thank you Tommy thank you Brandon for
joining me this morning to react to this
it was so much fun to to do this with
all of you we hope to do more of these
on the new rockstars channel uh and
again uh Jessica and I are going to be
teaming up to break down the Easter eggs
that you might have missed we didn't
cover something in this video it'll
probably be in that one that's coming to
the channel tomorrow
um so uh the best way to support new
rockstars is growing network is to get
one of our merch options over at nerd
riot.shop we're gonna have some
Guardians of the Galaxy designs that are
a lot of fun Tommy's wearing her John
Wick shirt I'm wearing something from
our Deep dive collection Brandon's got
uh stuff from our main new rock stars
collection and T what do you got what
kind of forever oh yeah baby
um so yeah that's really one way to
support us directly here also subscribe
to new rockstars on YouTube all social
platforms you can follow us on all
social media at mastertainment Tommy
Bechtel that EA boss at grid and Barrick
and thank you so much for watching and
we'll see you next time bye everybody
bye bye
[Music]